[Music]
my name is Jason I'm a product manager
on Google cloud platform and as you can
see today is we're going to be talking
about building service applications with
Google cloud functions okay before we do
that we might need to just describe what
this word this weird word service that
we see popping up all over the place
actually means and you might think that
it means no service right well kind of
it could mean any one or all of these
things so there no need to manage
servers no need to even think about
servers there's a provisioning argument
maybe it's about what you pay for
maybe it's not about billing maybe it's
about developer experience or the unit
of deployment etc the purpose of today
I'm just going to narrow that scope so
I'm going to talk about these four
things service by definition of
something that you don't even need to
think about servers you pay only port
you use its event oriented and you
deployed functions and not apps okay
well what does that really mean in order
to answer that question I'm going to
tell a little story this is Tony and
Tony has an app and he's going to run
his app on a virtual machine and so he
launches the app and the app gets some
traffic and his virtual machine is
humming along nicely and then his app
gets more popular and he gets more
traffic and now he can't sit on a single
virtual machine that's cool
he just gets a second virtual machine
and the extra traffic that couldn't sit
on the first one flows over to the
second one now if he's got some sort of
load balancing ahead of this it probably
looks more something like this and
that's fine so yeah okay this is a
problem with this
and it's these gray boxes this means
he's over provisioned so he's he's
bought and paid for capacity that he's
not using and that's costing him money
okay let's see if we can do better so I
start with the virtual machines but this
time we're not gonna deploy an
application into that virtual machine
we're just going to deploy the container
and then when that container exhausts
its resources I deploy another container
and so on and so on and so on and then
if I'm load balancing maybe looks
something like that
so that looks good but then what if I
need one more well I need a whole new
virtual machine so we're kind of back to
square one we still have another
provisioning problem I'm still
provisioning capacity but I'm not using
and that's costing me money okay let's
try again what we just removed the
server now when he wants to add a new
container we just add in your container
sweet we still do have some waste here
though you can see there's still a bunch
of gray boxes there so that's still
somewhat over provisioned and still
costing money what if we do shrink this
unit of computer rather than deploying a
VM image or a container what if we made
it as small as possible so each little
unit is going to have its own amount of
capacity and so the amount that we're
over provisioning is even less you're
still going to have a little bit you're
not going to get it rid of it entirely
but this is a much better place to be so
you end up in this world where you have
independent units of compute independent
functions but scale independently and
the amount of over-provisioning is as as
low as it can be
by scale independently they're isolated
from one another
stateless and they more closely match
the traffic pattern so some functions
will execute frequently some functions
but so much sleep okay so that's broadly
speaking I serve a view of computing
that's service and why and what that
means and why it's important but how
would you use this and why does this
why's is what is this matter to you so
just hold that thought longer switch
gears and talk about some use cases
imagine you're building a booking system
I apologize this is a somewhat dry and
boring examples but it'll serve the
purpose you have some applications some
bit of compute that's accepting data
maybe successive orders and you want to
write those orders to some back-end
storage system in this case I'm choosing
cloud storage as the example and so
that's really the guts of your
application just take orders and write
in the storage now you have a new
requirement maybe you want to do some
indexing or some processing of this
order before it goes to storage and so
you implement encode some indexing or
some library that does this work for you
but maybe that libraries or that code
that you've written depends on a
database so I need to write out to a
database or an index and maybe it needs
some special file or rules to do that
and probably it needs some sort of
special authentication so that's okay
you put all that into your application
and it looks good meanwhile elsewhere
you have another application completely
separate that's taking some other data
but it needs to do something similar
this time maybe taking invoices and it's
right under storage and then maybe you
also need to index that data as well and
you want to reuse some of this code that
you've written over in the orders side
so now again you need the same database
network and authentication configuration
that you had previously and that's fine
that will work and that happens
routinely
but this might be a problem if duplicate
is this configuration and these settings
in this authentication in two different
places not to mention duplicating the
code so what does that mean for things
like security things like deployment if
you change if you change this library
you have to do you have to deploy both
versions of your application
simultaneously let's see if we can
improve this so same application two
different sides of it invoices and
orders this time we're going to
implement a separate API and the
applications are going to call that API
rather than writing directly to storage
and that API is going to write the file
to storage and it's going to do all the
indexing and have those dependencies
this is plastically what we might term
in a very simplistic way a
micro-services approach where you
separate logic into services rather than
making it in to the application and this
is totally fine great architecture works
well Tony loves it
there's one small challenge with this
and that is that you have now previously
we were writing your recall we're
writing from the compute to storage
directly and the stories let's say was a
managed service like cloud storage so it
had SLA Zanden had all sorts of uptime
guarantees and now we've created our own
API that we have to scale ourselves and
have to manage ourselves and so we've
introduced a point of failure here it's
not terrible and there's many ways to
mitigate that but you now do have to
think like how do I deal with that
failure how does the application deal
with the failure to index the data what
does it do so we might be able to do one
step set up same application this time
I'm going to go back to what I had
before I'm writing directly to storage
what if the storage system itself was
aware of that right and it couldn't you
need an event so when the write occurred
when the mutation in storage occurred it
would emit an event and then I could
attach code to that event and that code
would have the dependencies so in this
model I've solved
sort of two problems in one I've solved
the original problem of duplication of
configuration encode and I've also
solved the problem of depending not
depending on a managed service and and
the reliability challenges that may
present so it looks good right well
there is one more issue here those two
applications were pretty heavy late and
there are acquired virtual machines
under a lot of load but this one little
piece that I've pulled out doesn't get
called all the time or maybe doesn't
need many resources so now I'm back to
this over-provisioning situation if only
I had a smaller unit of compute that I
could use in place of that and the good
news is that we do suite so Google Cloud
functions is is that lightweight small
unit of compute it's a service
environment to build and connect cloud
services with code the characteristics
of cloud functions are this you don't
need to even think about service if you
pay only for what you use it is event
oriented and you deploy in units of
functions not apps and you'll recall
that this is where we started in our
definition okay pretty simple diagram
but just to give a sense of what that
looks like your cloud environment will
emit events as I mentioned mutation on
storage but it might mean event mutation
on a database might be an event also
external services will emit events
typically this is materialized as a web
callback or something like that so it
commits to github you can configure that
to call you back to the web hook over
HTTP the function will come to life
respond to that event and then from
within the function you can do anything
that you can do in a normal computing
environment you can call an API you can
write back to the database you can call
an external API in cloud functions
within Google we have two flavors an
HTTP function is a function you deploy
with an HTTP trigger and we'll give you
back immediate
the URL with a TLS certificate so it's
secure and you can curl that straight
away that would be for synchronous use
cases the web book callback will work
out of box for this the second flavor is
the background function this is where it
happens asynchronously there's an event
bus in between typically cloud pub/sub
this is where you don't need to know the
outcome of the function in real time
you're happy for it to be processed in
the background and typically this will
be as a result of an event being emitted
from a cloud service so let's have a
look at each of these in a little bit
more detail HTTP this is the simplest
hello world HTTP function you can
imagine we give you an HTTP request in
response objects this is in node anyone
familiar with node the request and
response is literally an express jeaious
request in response and so if you've
ever use Express J's then you know how
to do this a couple of things to point
out I just mentioned it's just a regular
request response and then you have the
full access to the response object you
don't need to do any sort of crazy
translations on the way in all the way
out it's just regular old HTTP this is
what a deploy might look like for that
from the command line we also have the
web UI which I'll show you in a little
while you just deployed the function you
give the stage bucket which is where we
store your deployment while where while
we're building building the function and
then you decides the trigger HTTP and
we'll give you back a URL background
function
very similar the only difference here is
instead of anak request in response
we'll give you an event which is the
event that was emitted from the cloud
service database mutation storage
mutation etc and we give you a call back
the call back is because in runtime
environments like node everything is
asynchronous you might be doing some
work asynchronously and you need to tell
us when your function is is done and so
you call the call back if you don't like
using callbacks that's cool
you can return a promise in fact you can
just return it's great value we'll treat
it as a promise again before the people
in the audience familiar with node in
JavaScript this is particularly useful
if you're using a third-party library
that's going to return a promise we
don't have to do any kind of like magic
you just return what they gave you and a
couple of examples of deploying
background functions so one here is
figuring off a cloud storage bucket the
other is triggering off a cloud pub/sub
topic dependencies it would be unusual I
think for you to write a bit of code
that has no dependencies on any other
modules or any other libraries typically
you will depend on numerous libraries of
your own or typically third-party
libraries in a node.js environment they
are expressed in a manifest file called
a package.json you declare your
dependencies in there and then there's a
tool called
npm node package manager that will
resolve those dependencies download all
the files and package up your app that
means that you can do something like
this you can require this external
dependency in your code and typically
you would declare it like this in your
package of JSON so when you deploy your
file function we will actually run npm
install for you so you don't have to
resolve those dependencies and zip them
up into a big fat zip and send them to
us you just send us your source code in
your manifest and we'll handle the rest
and this is what the deployed command
looks like if you're using a manifest
file it's the same as it was before
so nothing changes we just suck that up
and run npm install in the cloud logging
and monitoring so from your cloud
function you just write a consult upload
commanders you would do normally as you
will do anywhere else we will capture
that and write it to spec driver logging
from sector IV logging you can do a
bunch of interesting things you can pipe
those logs to bigquery you can set up a
filter to pipe those logs to a cloud
pub/sub topic and have another function
execute in response to that if you have
an uncaught exception in your code that
will get sent to stack driver errors
from there you can set up alerts to tell
you that something's on unusually wrong
that we didn't expect with the function
and all this is available through CLI UI
and api then monitoring we report the
essential and retrieve that you need how
many times your function is being
invoked how long what ran for and how
much memory did it use okay what what
does the environment look like that we
run in this comes up particularly for
those who might be running any native
libraries and by native I mean code that
needs to be compiled against the
underlying operating systems so cloud
functions run in an open environment
meaning that we just have a vanilla
flavor of Debian Linux we have a vanilla
flavor of nodejs we pre install
imagemagick just because that's a very
commonly used native library we give you
a local disk at /tmp
it within the environment you're
automatically authenticated against
other digital services so you don't have
to bundle in any authentication tokens
or consider how you authenticate your
function against other services
in your project it's automatically done
for you and the last point is about the
compilation some node modules will have
a native component and when you run npm
install it's going to compile that
native code if you run in PM and so on a
composited code on your Mac laptop and
then you deploy to an on Mac environment
you might have a bad day so the
advantage of having npm install' run for
you is that you just have to name the
dependency we will run npm install we
will run the compilation step and by
definition it's going to run on the same
environment that we going to execute on
so you don't run into these crazy
incompatibilities if the node module
you're using doesn't prepackaged a
compilation step and it depends on some
library that is not a little part of the
node module nine times out of ten you
can go and download the pre-compile
debian version of that library and
because it's just a standard debian
environment that should work if you
really really really have to compile
your own library onto the image onto the
same image then you don't get this image
from us you just go get it from the
internet
okay locals at all so this is great
about this environment I'm writing my
functions I'm deploying them I'm
executing them but it's a little slow in
the sense that I have to go through the
whole deploy process every time I want
to make a change it would be great if we
gave you a local emulation environment
so you can build and test and iterate
and debug your functions locally before
you deploy them so this is available
today this npm install the emulator it
runs a simulated environment of the of
the cloud environment for your cloud
functions has exactly the same api
surface area so if you wanted to write
tooling around how to deploy functions
using an API that tooling will work with
the emulator so you can easily switch
between emulator and and wipe code and
you can debug with this so it has a
command to enable the debugger and then
you can attach your favorite IDE to that
and
step through your JavaScript code
deployment I already touched on a little
bit but I want to walk you through how
this works so you can deploy in line we
have an inline code editor in the UI or
you can deploy via the command line or
wiring API if you're deploying directly
from your local file system will zip it
up for you without the dependencies or
with the dependencies if you want to
send them with us for or for whichever
reason you like and we'll send it to the
API and we'll run the build process from
there if you don't want to deploy
directly from your local file system you
can also deploy from your github or
bitbucket repository this is done using
a tool called cloud source repositories
will automatically keep in sync your
cloud repository with your github
repository and so you're actually
deploying from cloud for three posts but
it is kept in sync with github so you
don't really have to interact with it
you just commit to get or to github
rather and then trigger a deploy and the
your clouds will 3po will sync so I want
to talk a little bit about what actually
happens at the fly time so you've
written your code let's say you're using
the CLI you've gone T clouds beta
functions deploy and then what happens
so you hit deploy as I said we zip it up
if it's in the CLI when it gets to the
server we run NPM install if if there
are already packages there then we might
just run NPM rebuild to capture any
native compilation that needs to happen
for the platform we have internally a
thing called create version so what this
is doing is saying okay we have a new
version of this function I'm going to
create a new version so the existing
version continues to exist and before we
do anything I'm going to health check
that I'm going to make sure that that
thing is ok that means that the
environment spun up correctly the image
has been created correctly
the run timer started correctly we can't
check that your function is going to
work because your function of course may
have side effects so we can't invoke
your function but we can we can go as
far as we can do everything but that to
make sure that everything's ok and if
everything's ok we'll mark the
deployment is complete and then we'll
gradually move traffic from the old
version to the new version ok so that
all sounds great
now what do I do one of these cases that
pops up quite a lot and I've touched on
it a few times is lightweight ETL so far
comes in hits storage or comes into the
cloud and you want to do some
transformation of it before it goes
somewhere else so one solution to that
is have the file hit storage immediately
have storage call the cloud function and
maybe from there you want to write it
write it to a database or maybe you want
to send it to bigquery or maybe use more
right back to storage with a mutated
version of that file this comes up in
things like image processing video
processing indexing like in my earlier
example energy extraction you know you
might want to send the image to the
vision API to pull the entities out of
it content sanitation and filtering
those sorts of things
Semmy else is one of the customers we
have using cloud functions for this
there in here because I thought they're
really interesting use case they have
around 150,000 sensors in or chah's
tracking things like temperature and
pressure humidity those sorts of things
and they aggregate all that data in the
orchard and send it back to the cloud
and it passes through a cloud function
on its way through and through that fab
function they're doing some filtering
before it gets to the database now the
use case we see a lot and I also alluded
to is micro services and web books so
the diffusion flavors of how this might
work one is the client
is is calling typically via HTTP calling
the cloud function directly so the
client is outside of the cloud the cloud
functions inside the cloud and they just
call it very cool you can think of this
as a micro service the client may also
be inside the club in this case API so
similar to a micro service but it's
where you the client is calling the the
cloud function and treating it as an API
in the same way that you would if you
were to build a website with an express
exposed endpoints the mobile client is
pointing directly to the cloud functions
web book this is example I gave before
where somebody like a github might be
calling you back or maybe you're sending
an SMS using Tullio and they're going to
call you back with a web hook when it's
done so micro-services data ingestion
api's callbacks from external services
good example here is vroom-vroom are the
largest used car seller on eBay
and they accept data from partners over
a network of partners they want to
accept data using cloud functions as a
data ingestion mechanism as an API for
their partners to call the last one I
want to talk about today is more of a
fun use case so BOTS and actions so this
is where some messaging clients some
chat clients some voice enabled device
is going to use a cloud function to
create a custom command something to
extend the behavior of this of this tool
so we use the cloud function for this
for doing this typically again enabled
over HTTP messaging blocks things like
adding custom actions to Google
assistant and home automation so the
example here is made up
they created a custom slack command and
so when you type this slack command into
their slack channel it will fire a file
function that will create a ticket in
Deraa
part of their way to automate their
development processes this is my own
artistic talent slingshot it's supposed
to be a drum and then my wife said that
it looks like a bowl of rice it's
supposed to be a drum and supposed to
remind me that this is a drum roll you
may have already heard but we also now
support firebase so you can cause a
function a cloud function to be invoked
from a mutation in the firebase real
time database from lifecycle events on
authentication and also from analytics
events from your mobile client but I
want to steal their thunder too much
they have they have a session today at 4
o'clock I encourage you to go and have a
look at that and you can see here just
those examples in the context of
firebase so processing payments for an
external provider sending an email or an
SMS back-end service integration so
connecting to the rest of the cloud and
then funnel optimization is and is
leveraging things like analytics to know
what the end users are doing and to
react to that with code so great example
might be depending on the end user is
doing you might want to send them a push
notification when they enter eggs at a
particular analytics cohort the cloud
functions is in beta today it's
available for everyone to use just go to
it URL you can find out more that's all
I have in terms of content does anyone
want to see its demo
let me rephrase that they don't want to
see me try to do a demo and have a fail
catastrophically and be embarrassed
yeah more people great ok switch to the
demo please okay this looks confusing
under zoomed out a little bit that's
where the box a little bit let me see if
I can make that a little bit better
that's worse
okay I'll live with it okay what are you
looking at here all these gray boxes at
the top you can think of those as users
calling your function now unfortunately
when I when we were creating this demo
we thought it'd be easy just to run it
in a browser it turns out the browser is
not great at generating many many
concurrent HTTP requests so even though
there's I think about 80 boxes on the
screen there we're not talking 80
concurrent requests there just going to
fire off the quest as quickly as they
can each little box represents a request
when the cloud function executes it's
just going to do one thing it's going to
return a color and the box is going to
render the color that it returns and
that's it once we speak this off we'll
see these boxes switching color to
whatever color the function is returning
for attaining the same color for
everyone then I'm going to show you the
deploy process I'm going to live I'm
going to redeploy a function I'm going
to change the color and visually you
should see all these boxes flick over to
the new color and down below what you'll
see is the latency the median response
time from executing this function so
let's see if this works okay
these are all my boxes changing color
and below you can see the latency now
I'm going to switch over to my cloud
console here's my send color function
I'm just going to edit so you can see
here this is where I'm sending the
responses Justin HTTP function I've got
some cool stuff there just to make it
callable from the browser just ignore
that so I'm going to change this to send
green rather than blue hit save and
recalling what I mentioned before that's
going to send that that deployment to
the cloud it's going to run npm install
it's going to build an image it's going
to create a version a bit of switch
across across so you can see it it's
going to create a version it's going to
health check that version and assuming
the health check passes and everything's
okay if that will become the current
version and right on cue right on cue
it's going to change
so that's just showing how easy it is to
deploy a function and if you had some
error some problem in it the existing
function keeps ticking and we will help
check everything and then we'll switch
across to the new version and you'll
notice that the colors didn't flick
immediately that's more a browser issue
but it may be that there's a traffic
video rather requests are currently
being served will complete before they
get to the new version so you might get
some timing issues in that and you saw
that reflected this okay so that's all I
have today
[Music]
[Music]